>>> TWO WEEKS AGO, FILMMAKER AND
LIFE DOCUMENTING THE HORRORS OF
THE BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE.
TRIBUTES IMMEDIATELY POURED IN
FOR THE FILMMAKER.
THE HEAD OF POLICE IN KYIV SAID
AT THE TIME THAT RENAUD, QUOTE,
PAID WITH HIS LIFE IN AN ATTEMPT
TO SHED LIGHT.
HE WAS TRAVELING AT THE TIME
WITH A PHOTOJOURNALIST, JUAN
ARREDONDO WHO BARELY ESCAPED
WITH HIS OWN LIFE AND IS NOW
RECEIVING CARE AT THE IRVING
MEDICAL CENTER.
IN HIS FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE
THAT DAY, I WAS ABLE TO SPEAK
WITH ARREDONDO ABOUT HIS FRIEND
AND THE ATTACK HE CALLS AN
AMBUSH.
WE WARN YOU SOME OF THE IMAGES
YOU'LL SEE ARE GRAPHIC, BUT AS
WE ALWAYS TRY TO COMMUNICATE IN
THESE INSTANCES, WE THINK IT'S
NECESSARY TO SHOW THEM TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
UKRAINE AND WHAT BRENT RENAUD
GAVE HIS LIFE TRYING TO CAPTURE.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED?
>> YEAH, YEAH.
I REMEMBER THE DAY VERY CLEARLY.
>> WHAT WAS THE PLAN THAT DAY?
>> SO THE REASON WE WERE IN
KYIV, WE WERE LOOKING FOR
REFUGEES, BUT THEY ALREADY TOLD
US THAT THERE WERE NO SHELTERS.
IT WAS JUST BASICALLY PEOPLE
BEING EVACUATED.
>> JUAN AR DON'T DOE AND HIS
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE BRENT
RENAUD WEREN'T LOOKING TO
DOCUMENT THE FIGHTING IN
UKRAINE.
INSTEAD THEY WANTED TO TELL THE
STORIES OF REFUGEES WHO WERE
FLEEING THE WAR.
THEY HEADED TO IRPIN, WHERE THEY
HEARD THOUSANDS OF CIVILIANS
WERE BEING EVACUATED.
AT THAT POINT IRPIN WAS -- THEY
HAD DESTROYED THE BRIDGE.
>> RIGHT.
>> FROM IRPIN TO PREVENT RUSSIAN
FORCES FROM BEING ABLE TO COME
ACROSS, AND WE HAD SEEN ON
SATURDAY CLARISSA WARD HAD DONE
SOME LIVE SHOTS AT THE POINT
WHERE HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS
OF DISPLACED PEOPLE WERE COMING
OUT OF IRPIN, KIND OF BEING
HELPED ACROSS THE BRIDGE.
THEN LINDSEY ADARIO WAS THERE
WHEN A ROCKET HIT IRPIN AND A
FAMILY WAS KILLED.
>> WE WERE THERE ON A SUNDAY, SO
THAT WAS AFTER WHAT HAPPENED
WITH LINDSEY.
SO THAT WAS MUCH LATER THAT WEEK
WHERE FROM OUR UNDERSTANDING,
THAT PART WAS ALREADY -- THAT
WAS A HUMANITARIAN CORRIDOR.
WE DID SEE A SMALL -- WE SAW
MAYBE THREE CARS COMING IN.
THEY EVACUATED SOME CIVILIANS.
THEN WE ASKED, ARE THEY COMING
FROM ANOTHER BRIDGE?
AND THAT'S QUITE FAR, BUT IT'S
STILL A CORRIDOR.
SO WE DECIDED JUST TO START
WALKING.
>> AND IT WAS YOU AND BRENT?
>> IT WAS ME AND BRENT.
THAT'S WHEN -- WELL, TWO CARS,
TWO CIVILIAN CARS APPROACHED US,
BUT WE COULDN'T COMMUNICATE WITH
THEM, SO WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THEY WANTED.
THEN THE THIRD CAR THAT CAME
SPOKE SOME ENGLISH, AND WE SAID,
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THIS BRIDGE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE BEING
EVACUATED.
HE SAID, YEAH, I CAN TAKE YOU
GUYS THERE.
SO WE GOT ON THE CAR, AND, YOU
KNOW, IT MUST HAVE BEEN MAYBE
TEN, MAXIMUM 15 MINUTES WE WERE
RIDING, AND THERE WAS A
CHECKPOINT BUT IT WAS EMPTY.
AND THEN THERE WAS THE BAR
BARRICADES.
I WAS LOOKING OUT THE WINDOW,
AND I SAW IN THE TRENCHES TWO
MILITARY, ONE OF THEM PULL OUT
THE AK, AND I JUST SHOUTED WE'RE
GETTING SHOT.
>> COULD YOU TELL WHETHER THEY
WERE UKRAINIAN OR RUSSIAN?
>> NO.
IT WAS SO FAST.
WHAT LEADS ME TO THINK THEY WERE
RUSSIAN IS BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL,
THAT WAS THE CORRIDOR WHERE
PEOPLE WERE BEING EVACUATED, AND
WE JUST CAME ACROSS A CONVOY OF
MILITARY, UKRAINIAN MILITARY
THAT WERE JUST WALKING AND
PATROLLING.
BUT THEY SAID, YEAH, YOU CAN GO
THIS WAY.
>> THAT'S GOT TO BE SO SURREAL
TO ACTUALLY SEE TWO GUYS GET UP
AND START TO POINT --
>> YEAH.
>> TO SEE IT BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
>> WELL, I JUST -- I MEAN I --
YEAH, MY REACTION WAS JUST TO
SCREAM AND DUCK BECAUSE I
DIDN'T -- I DIDN'T THINK THEY
WERE GOING TO SHOOT, BUT THAT
WAS SORT OF MY INSTINCT.
BUT IT WAS SURREAL BECAUSE WE
WERE CONVINCED WE WERE IN A
PLACE THAT -- WAS THERE DANGER?
YES, THERE COULD HAVE BEEN.
BUT THERE WAS NOTHING THAT LED
US TO BELIEVE THAT WE WERE GOING
TO BE AMBUSHED OR ANYTHING.
>> ANY SENSE OF HOW MANY SHOTS?
>> IT WAS JUST A LOT.
I MEAN I CAN'T -- I TRY TO
REMEMBER, BUT IT WAS JUST KIND
OF RAINING.
THAT'S ALL I COULD HEAR IS JUST
HEAR IT HITTING WINDOWS, HEAR IT
HITTING THE KIND OF LIKE TIN,
LIKE METAL, AND THEN THAT'S WHEN
I FELT THAT I GOT SHOT.
I YELLED, I GOT SHOT, BUT I
DIDN'T GET ANY RESPONSE FROM
BRENT.
>> YOU WERE DOWN ON THE FLOOR IN
THE BACK SEAT?
>> ON THE FLOOR IN THE BACK
SEAT, YEAH.
>> COULD YOU TELL WHERE YOU HAD
BEEN SHOT?
>> YEAH, BECAUSE I FELT IT RIGHT
THERE.
I JUST TOUCHED IT, AND I FELT
LIKE THE BLEEDING.
>> AND IT ENTERED THROUGH --
>> THROUGH MY BUTTOCKS ON THE
LEFT.
BUT THEN I STARTED LIKE TAPPING
MY TOES JUST TO MAKE SURE IF I
COULD, YOU KNOW -- IF I LOST
ANYTHING.
I FEEL THEM AND I WAS LIKE,
OKAY, I'M FINE.
THEN I JUST KEPT YELLING TO THE
DRIVER.
JUST DRIVE, GO, GO, GO.
MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT BECAUSE
OF THE SOUND THE CAR WAS MAKING,
THE CAR MAYBE HAD BEEN DAMAGED.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SO HE STOPPED, AND THAT'S
WHEN I LOOKED UP, AND I SAW
BRENT, YOU KNOW, EXIT -- NOW I
KNOW IT WAS AN EXIT WOUND, BUT
IT WAS A WOUND HERE.
SO IT WAS BLEEDING.
I TRIED TO GRAB ON TO IT AND
MAYBE STOP THE BLEEDING.
>> WAS HE SAY ANYTHING?
>> HE WAS TRYING TO MUMBLE
THINGS, BUT I COULDN'T MAKE OUT
WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
THEN I SAW THE DRIVER GET OUT
AND WAVE AT ANOTHER CIVILIAN
CAR.
THEN, YOU KNOW, THEY -- WE WERE
TRYING TO GET -- THE DRIVER WAS
TRYING TO GET BRENT OUT.
I GOT OUT OF THE CAR, AND THEN
THEY JUST SHOVED ME INTO THIS
CAR AND DROVE ME OUT.
BUT I KEPT SAYING, YOU KNOW,
BRING BRENT, BRING BRENT.
AND I THINK AT THAT POINT IS
WHEN MAYBE BRENT WAS JUST -- HE
WAS DEAD ALREADY.
AND I REMEMBER JUST BEING IN
THAT CAR.
I PUT MY HAND ON THE WOUND, AND
I WAS STARTING TO FAINT.
I WAS LIKE, THIS CAN'T BE.
I CAN'T GO.
>> WE ALL IMAGINE HOW WOULD WE
REACT IN A SITUATION WHERE SHOTS
ARE BEING FIRED IN OUR
DIRECTION, AND YOU THINK
INTELLECTUALLY, OH THIS IS THE
WAY IT WOULD HAPPEN, OR THIS IS
THE WAY I WOULD DO.
WAS IT DIFFERENT THAN YOU HAD
EVER THOUGHT OF IT?
>> I CERTAINLY NEVER EXPERIENCED
AN AMBUSH LIKE THAT.
BUT THERE WAS A POINT THAT I
THOUGHT, THIS IS IT.
I'M GONE.
THEN I WAS LAYING DOWN ON THE
FLOOR, AND THERE WAS SO MUCH --
LIKE I COULD HEAR SO MUCH
HITTING THAT CAR THAT I THOUGHT,
OKAY, THIS IS IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO SURVIVE THIS.
AND I'VE NEVER EXPERIENCED THAT
SENSATION, THAT FEELING OF
KNOWING THAT THIS IS IT.
AND IT'S NOT -- IT'S NOT A
FEELING OF BEING AFRAID.
IT'S JUST COMING TO TERMS THAT
THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO.
THIS IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE THE
END.
AND THEN RIGHT AFTER THAT
THOUGHT IS WHEN I FELT THE SHOT,
AND I SHOUTED, I GOT SHOT.
AND I DON'T KNOW.
AND THEN IT JUST -- BUT IT
HAPPENED SO FAST, I COULDN'T
TELL HOW -- WHAT THE SPAN OF
TIME FROM THE MOMENT THE FIRST
SHOT WAS FIRED TO THE MOMENT WE
STOPPED.
>> I HOPE EVERYTHING WILL BE
OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS JUAN AT A HOSPITAL IN
KYIV RIGHT AFTER HE WAS SHOT.
DOCTORS FOUND A FRAGMENT OF THE
BULLET LODGED IN HIS LEG.
>> TELL ME, PLEASE, WHAT IS YOUR
NAME.
>> JUAN.
>> JUAN?
>> WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
>> THE U.S.
>> U.S.?
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU?
>> MY FRIEND IS BRENT RENAUD,
AND HE'S BEEN SHOT AND LEFT
BEHIND.
>> AND HOW IS HE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW?
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO --
>> I SAW HIM BEING SHOT IN THE
NECK, AND WE GOT SPLIT.
>> ONE SAYS HE DIDN'T LEARN
BRENT HAD DIED UNTIL AFTER HE
WAS OUT OF SURGERY, WHEN BRENT'S
BROTHER, CRAIG, CALLED HIM TO
TELL HIM THE NEWS.
WHAT WAS BRENT LIKE?
>> BRENT WAS A -- YOU KNOW, HE
WAS A GOOD FRIEND.
YOU KNOW, WE MET -- WE WERE
DOING A FELLOWSHIP UP AT HARVARD
AND THAT'S WHERE WE MET.
HE'S LIKE, WE DON'T HAVE A
SCHEDULE.
WE DON'T FOLLOW A SCHEDULE.
WE FOLLOW A STORY.
IF THAT REQUIRES BEING 20 HOURS
AWAKE OR WHATEVER IT TAKES TO
GET THAT STORY, WE'LL DO IT.
SO I UNDERSTOOD THAT, SO WE
WORKED WELL THAT WAY.
HE WAS ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT ME
BEING -- YOU KNOW, BEING WELL,
BUT ALSO LEARNING AND BECOMING
BETTER, AND SO -- AND IT'S RARE
TO HAVE A FRIEND TO WORK AND NOT
HAVE ANY -- WE NEVER HAVE ANY
DISAGREEMENTS OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, SO THAT WAS VERY SPECIAL.
>> WHEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS, DO YOU DREAM ABOUT IT?
>> SO THAT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
HAVING A HARD TIME SLEEPING.
THAT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE PARTS
THAT I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
IS BECAUSE I DON'T SLEEP FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME, AND I
NOTICE MY DREAMS ARE VERY VIVID.
AND IT'S ALWAYS IN THAT CAR.
I DON'T RECALL EVERYTHING --
>> IN YOUR DREAM, YOU'RE IN THAT
CAR.
>> I DON'T RECALL EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENS, BUT I DO KNOW I'M
FORCING MYSELF TO WAKE UP SO I
DON'T LIVE THAT.
SO I'M WAKING UP.
I'M VERY JUMPY ALL NIGHT, WAKE
UP IN SWEAT.
>> I WAS READING ABOUT THE
FUNERAL SERVICE THAT THEY HELD
FOR BRENT, WHICH SOUNDED REALLY
LOVELY.
IT SOUNDED LIKE THERE WAS A
REALLY BIG TURNOUT.
I UNDERSTAND YOU ASKED THAT A
POEM BE READ, THE INVICTUS.
>> YEAH.
>> WAS THAT A POEM THAT HE LIKED
OR --
>> IT WAS A POEM I LIKED AND
THAT I KEPT READING TO MYSELF.
IT MATTERS NOT HOW STRAIGHT THE
GATE OR CHARGED WITH PUNISHMENTS
THE SCROLL.
I AM THE MASTER OF MY FAITH.
I AM THE CAPTAIN OF MY SOUL.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO YOU?
>> I MEAN IT'S GOTTEN ME THROUGH
SOME REALLY DARK NIGHTS THESE
LAST TWO WEEKS, ESPECIALLY WHEN
I WAS GOING INTO SURGERY.
I KEPT SAYING THOSE LAST LINES.
I'M THE MASTER OF MY FAITH.
I'M THE CAPTAIN OF MY SOUL.
I NEED TO COME OUT ALIVE OF
THIS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
IT WASN'T MY TIME.
I KEEP ASKING THAT MYSELF.
WHY?
BUT THOSE NIGHTS THAT I WAS --
IT WAS -- YEAH, I